RUSSELL HARMON: My
name's Russ Harmon.
I'm a full-time software
engineer here at Google
like, I think, most
of you as well.
And thank you for coming.
This is Morten Kromberg.
He's the CTO of Dyalog,
which is an implementation
of a programming language.
And let's get started.
MORTEN KROMBERG: OK.
Well, thank you for coming.
And thank you, Russ, for
believing that they would come,
and inviting me to come and give
this talk about something which
is definitely not mainstream.
In fact, Dyalog is
an implementation
of an ancient programming
language called APL, which
I think is now 52 years old.
And I have been using it
for about 36 of those years.
I remember, I did a
similar talk previously
where a guy came up
to me afterwards.
And he said, you've been
using the same programming
language for 35 years,
and you're still happy?
As if that was completely
impossible and unthinkable.
So, I started off as
a young man should.
I spent the money I'd
made selling newspapers,
or delivering newspapers, and
buying this do-it-yourself kit.
I soldered all those integrated
circuits onto a board.
And I got this thing to work,
programed it in Z80 Bytecode.
I'd never soldered
anything before,
so it would only
run for about three
or four minutes before crashing.
Then things got a
little bit better.
I found Commodore started making
these really nice machines.
So I learned BASIC.
And so things we're
going fairly normally
until a friend of
the family one day
brought me down to the
place where he was working,
and he said, we're using
this thing called APL.
And he typed this expression
here, 1 2 3 + 4 5 6,
and the computer spat
out three numbers.
And I thought well,
that's the end of that.
And so I've been using
this technology now
for 35 years-ish.
I started out in 1979 a time--
well, Timesharing in those days
was when you were
sharing a computer, not
a condo in Mexico.
The customers were
paying about $1
per CPU second on
this machine, which
was around the other side
of the world in Toronto.
I was using it
from Oslo, Norway.
And $1 per 1,000
characters of output
that they received
over the network.
It's not as bad as it
sounds, because it actually
took several seconds
for that to print out.
So you were still getting
some value for money.
And now if we get to the recent
end of my experience with APL,
the last couple of
things we've done
is we've put out a
Raspberry Pi version, which
I think is significantly more
powerful computer than the 360.
Maybe doesn't have
the same I/O capacity,
but certainly things have
changed a bit in this time.
And last week, we also
released a version for the Mac.
I see there are a few Macs here.
So you can now get this, and
play with it on your Macs.
So for me, it's
been a love affair
lasting a very long time.
But of course not
everybody was keen
on APL when they saw
it for the first time.
This is perhaps one.
If you search on the
internet, there's
still a lot of very old
stuff you'll find about APL.
This is perhaps one of the most
famous statements about APL.
If you actually
read up on it, you
will find that Dijkstra wasn't
that uniformly negative on APL.
And anyway, I think
there was a proposal that
was arrogance should be measured
on a scale called the Dijkstra
scale.
But anyway, as you
grow up, and you
learn to receive
feedback from people,
you learn how to
read what people say.
And there's part of
this that I really like.
You may be surprised, I
like this last line here.
I think being a coding
bum is actually something
that's a positive statement.
You want to conserve your
energy when you're writing code.
Now the history of
APL is very long,
and the language is
quite different from
other programming languages.
And I think it's important to
spend just a little bit of time
looking at the man who invented
it, who is passed away.
I guess one of the few
programming language creators,
there's still only
a handful, who
lived-- he lived until he
was 84 and passed away.
It's not because he
passed away young.
So he was originally
on a farm, and he
went to a one-room school.
He did nine years of schooling,
and went back to the farm.
And that could have
been the end of it,
if it hadn't been for
being drafted by the army.
So, whatever you think of the
army, at least in this case,
turned out to be a very good
thing that they drafted Ken.
And he almost finished
high school in the service.
And he found that
he really enjoyed
mathematics and teaching
it to his fellow soldiers.
And they told him that if he
didn't go back to university
after the war, they were
going to come and beat him up.
So he had to do that.
So he embarked on an
academic career, which became
quite an interesting one.
He did doctoral work at Harvard
with Aiken and Leontief,
who later won the Nobel
Prize in economics
for his input-output matrices.
Which, I think, also recognizes
a very early precursor
of some of the
algorithms in Google
page ranking, from what I
was able to read yesterday
when I was researching that.
But he taught at Harvard.
He was teaching mathematics
after doing this work.
And he was really
getting frustrated
with what he felt
was the inadequacy
of mathematical notation.
And he developed
his own notation,
wrote a book about it in 1962.
But the people at Harvard
said, well, all you've done
is publish that little book, and
they didn't grant him tenure.
And he moved off to IBM
to work with people there,
who then, after APL had been
used to teach mathematics
and matrix algebra
for some years,
implemented the first
interpreter for the language.
So the language was initially
designed as a communication
tool for humans, and used
in that way on blackboards
for some years before the
first interpreter was created.
And of course for
that little book,
Iverson did later
receive the Turing award
for his pioneering
work in education,
in Timesharing, and so on.
So, here's what was
really winding Ken up,
especially when he was doing
the work on mathematics.
He found that mathematics
had all these strange forms.
There was a very wide
variety of syntactical forms.
There were very strange
and inconsistent
precedence rules-- what order
you do the suffixes, and so on.
And particularly when he
was working with matrices,
it was pretty frustrating.
And so he came up
with this language,
which has a very small
amount of different syntaxes.
But rather than look
at the PowerPoint,
I'm going to do
some live coding.
Most of the interesting
part of this presentation
will hopefully be
the live coding.
So those of you who
can't read this,
it may be worth
coming over here.
Because I think at
least half of the time
is going to be me
typing expressions.
Is that wrapping?
We had a bit of fun with
the resolution here.
Am I on?
I'm in now.
OK.
So, the first syntax you need is
to be able to create a matrix,
arrays are fundamental
to the language.
And just by juxtaposing
things, you create lists.
So here we have a bunch
of numbers, three scalars,
and a vector.
And you can see the structure.
The system, if you don't
assign it to a variable,
it just outputs the result
of whatever expression
you've typed.
You'll see me use this
lamp symbol quite a lot.
This is the lamp,
it illuminates code.
There's a lot of that kind of
fun in the choice of symbols
in APL.
So, this is an array of two,
we call them character vectors;
you might call them strings.
Arrays can be named.
And of course you can assign
another name to something.
And then we'll make
a change to b here,
and this is just to demonstrate
that all the arrays in APL
are value types.
These are not reference arrays.
But they are immutable, and
they are all value types.
So here is an array
called FormProps.
And this is really just
to show you, very briefly,
that we can do other
things in calculations.
We can create a form
with those properties.
And then you have
an object model
where the properties
can be arrays,
and I can set the caption.
And I'm creating
a list box inside,
which I will set to
have a background color.
And I'm just going to do
that so I can maintain
a list of the different
syntaxes as we go along here,
since we're not looking
at the PowerPoint.
So after the array,
the next form
we have is a function
followed by an array.
So, for example, iota
6, the index generator
generates an array of
the numbers up to 6.
This little thing pointing
down with a little step
at the bottom is floor.
The font size is just
a little bit too big.
Is it OK if I bring the font
size down just a little bit?
Yes, we have lost a bit
of real estate here.
OK, so itemwise map
is implicit for all
of what we call scalar
functions, which
is about half-- at least
half of the functions.
So if you have an array, it
just applies the function
to every element of
the array without you
having to say, map, or for
each, or anything like that.
So the exclamation mark standing
before an array is factorial.
And then we'll move
on to the next syntax.
There's only six
or seven of these.
The next one is a function
with an array on both sides.
We call that a dyadic,
or infix, function.
The first one we would
call a monadic function.
Unfortunately, we started
using that terminology
before monads were invented
in functional programming.
And it's a bit hard.
But I'm trying to use
prefix and infix here,
to make it a little
bit more palatable.
So, the thing that
would have been ceiling,
if you give it two arguments,
it takes the largest
of the two arguments.
If you have the exclamation mark
with something on both sides,
it's related to the factorial.
It's the binomial, or
the gamma, function.
If they're a floating
point, we have division,
and so on and so forth.
And of course, not
everything works.
We have errors.
And the same if you try and
divide a number by a character.
That doesn't work.
But here is this expression that
made me fall in love with APL.
Two arrays, one
function in the middle,
and it just maps without
you having to say anything.
And it applies in the
same way to virtually
all of these functions,
and also any functions
that you might write yourself,
typically will just apply.
Now, if there is not the
same number on both sides,
you get what we
call a length error.
But if there's exactly
one number on the one side
and an array on the
other, we do something
called scalar extension,
and the single number
is applied to all of the items.
So far, we've only used lists.
Here is a matrix.
So this is the 2 by
4 reshape of iota 12.
So that gives us-- iota
8 would have been enough.
I think I had a different
example in mind when
I started writing that line.
And I can do matrix
plus matrix, any rank.
It all works exactly
the same way.
There's no different rules to
learn as the rank increases.
Writing rank in variant
code is trivial.
Right.
So I'm just changing
the print precision,
because I'm going to take
the base 2 logarithm.
So again, for a
matrix on the right,
and a single number
on the left, we
can take the base 2 logarithm
of all of these numbers.
Now, not all of the functions
are these scalar functions.
So all the mathematical and
logical functions are scalar.
But the iota, if you give it
two arguments, is a look-up.
So it returns something
with the same shape
as the right argument.
But it's looking each of
the items up in the left.
So it's still array-oriented,
but it's not doing
things a scalar at a time.
Not everything is
a scalar function.
And then we have, again,
slightly different terminology
in APL.
We distinguish between what we
call functions and operators.
An operator is something
which typically takes
a function as its operand.
And the syntax there is you
have a function preceding
an operator.
For example, plus reduce,
the operator is on the right,
and it's acting on the plus.
Again, I can name functions the
same way I can name variables.
So that gives me a
function that does
the plus reduction of an array.
So plus reduce is the same
as putting the plus function
in between all the
items of the arrays.
For some of you who are
doing functional programming,
these concepts will be familiar.
And they mostly came
out of APL originally.
A lot of the terminology
was invented back
in the late '50s and '60s.
And all scalar functions
apply in the same way.
So anything that
takes two arguments,
you can do a reduction, and
it's going to just do the work.
There's also, if you turn
the slash the other way,
you get a scan, where it
takes a prefix of a vector
with one item, then two items,
three items, four items,
and does the reduction.
So we have the accumulating
sum if you use it with plus.
And then the reduction
also can take
a left argument,
which is the window
size that you want to use.
So you can say, I'd like to do
the plus reduction of length
three vectors.
If we do a catenate reduction
with a length three,
you can see that just catenates
the items together and doesn't
do an operation on them.
And you can see the windows
that were processed one by one.
And then finally, we have the
function, operator function.
A dyadic operator that
works on two functions,
where the one that you
will all be familiar with
is the vector product.
So plus dot times inner product.
So plus dot times is equivalent
to the plus reduction
of the map of times, which is
how you do a vector product,
of course.
But in APL that's a
completely general construct,
so it's not just plus and times.
In many tools like
MATLAB or R, you
will have this thing
extracted and presented
as a matrix product, or vector
product, a named function.
But in APL-- this is just
restating it the same way.
In APL, it's completely general.
So you could do an or
dot equals, which says,
are any of the items equals?
So it maps the equals, and
then it does an or reduction.
OK?
But that's nearly all
the syntax there is.
The only thing you need
to remember when you're
trying to parse the
syntax is that there
are no precedence rules.
Iverson was wound
up about all the
different-- when you do sine
squared of x, what order are
the operations done?
So he picked this
one, which he felt
was perhaps most representative
of the general precedence.
Or this one was nice
and easy, anyway.
And he said the
argument to the function
is the result of executing
everything that's on the right.
So this is the
factorial of iota six.
So there are no
precedence rules.
You just apply the function
to the result of computing
what's on the right.
And if it's a dyadic function,
then it essentially works
in the same way, but the left
arguments are also included.
So, if you were coming from
another programming language,
and you looked at
something like this,
you might assume that it's going
to do-- that's 10 divided by 5,
minus 1.
But in APL, of course, it's
10, divided by 5 minus 1.
And it doesn't give you the
result you were thinking of.
So remember that as you read
the rest of this, if you can.
And the final piece of syntax
is an array, the square bracket
indexing, which you would
be familiar with from most
languages.
The thing that's slightly
different about APL
is that you can
index with an array.
So the indices can be arrays.
I think you do see that
in some other languages.
So the shape of the
result has the same shape
as the index array, rather than
the data that's being indexed.
Of course, once
functional programming
became better
understood-- most of APL
predates really an
understanding of what
functional programming was.
So in 1984, it was
decided that there
should be a function, comprised
by over-striking the two
square brackets,
the squad indexing,
so that you could do indexing
in a functional style.
OK.
So if this has whetted
your appetite at all,
there is a website called
TryAPL.org where you
can type your APL expressions.
And there's an APL keyboard
that pops up if you need it.
And there's a primer page, where
you can hover over each one.
I mean, this list
here is all that there
is to learn about the language.
It may look a bit intimidating
with the squiggles,
but there's not
that much to learn.
You can hover over
these in TryAPL,
and you can see the
definition of each one.
And in the Windows
product, and on the Mac,
we have this language bar where
you can hover over the symbols,
and you can get the definitions.
We run a programming competition
for students each year.
And we had the winner one year
say, he would read the problem
description, and then he would
just hover with the mouse
slowly from left
to right until he
saw how to solve the problem.
And that was all the
documentation he needed.
So if your brain clicks when
you see this array notation,
there's these six rules,
and there's 40 functions,
and off you go.
Of course, there's more
to building applications
than that.
So, briefly back to
PowerPoint, unfortunately.
So, we've looked at that.
So just to recap
the fundamentals.
There's only one data type
in APL, the immutable array.
There's a little star
there that we'll get to
at the bottom of the slide.
Each item is either a number, or
a character, or another array.
For example, a single number
is a zero-dimensional array,
but it's still
considered an array.
It's not different type.
There isn't different
syntax to deal with it.
For most primitive
functions, map is implicit.
The functions are
either prefix or infix,
but the operators are
either postfix or infix.
And I don't know how
Iverson and his compatriots,
when they were designing the
language, came up with that.
But there's something
magical about this interplay
between the functions being
prefix and the operators
postfix when you're
designing a DSL.
So writing an embedded
DSL is typically
how a lot of APL
application development
is done, with the
end user synthesizing
their own functions from
these building blocks.
The order of execution we looked
at, and here's the little star.
We added-- at least
in Dyalog APL,
we added the ability to have
objects; so like these forms,
like dot net objects, or other
types of external objects.
And of course once
you have an item
in an array which is an object,
you lose the immutability.
Because that thing
is a reference type.
And we're not going to copy
them when we copy the arrays.
So, how did this
work then in the end?
He had this list, and he came
up with the new notation.
And let's organize them and see.
OK.
So, that's a times b.
That's the e to the power x,
no left argument, and the power
function means e to the power.
x divided by y.
The base b logarithm of a.
Notice the symbol is a log
seen edgewise, at the same time
as it's clearly related
to this one, right?
So there's a lot of that
kind of mnemonic stuff
to help you learn the language.
The nth root is a to the
power reciprocal of n.
Matrix multiplication is
like vector multiplication.
If you have two
matrices, it just
does the vector product on
the columns on the one side,
and the row on the other.
fgx is f g x.
The third trigonometric
function squared.
Sigmas and pis are
easily expressed
using plus reduce something
times iota something.
And OK, there isn't going to be
room to the right of this one.
But it still maps.
I mean, if you are accustomed
to mathematical notation,
the translation
of this into that
is not a very difficult thing.
And once you have experience
with the language,
although it clearly
executes from right to left,
we would say you read
it from left to right.
So to read that statement
there, you would say,
well, it's two times a divided
into minus b plus or minus
the square root of
b squared minus 4ac,
which is probably how you
would read the math as well.
And if you're writing good APL
code, at least in my group,
if you can't read it
from left to right,
you should probably
split the function up.
But that's something that
they're different opinions
about that, of course.
So, APL was instrumental
in discovering
functional programming.
And John Backus, the
inventor, I think, of FORTRAN.
And Backus [INAUDIBLE] in
his Turing Award lecture,
recognized Ken's work.
But he did go on to
say-- he wasn't quite as
unhappy as Dijkstra, of course.
But he was still
unhappy with the fact
that there were the world of
expressions and statements,
and there were only these
three functional forms.
There were actually
four, he missed scan.
But since then, I
mean, that was in 1977.
So APL today, although many
people equate APL with,
they learned it once.
They did some work in a
bank in the '70s or '80s.
And they're not
aware of the work
that's been done since then.
So, we have new
functional forms.
We have ways of defining
functions in a lexical style,
a functional lexical style.
So the first function here is
the definition of the average.
Omega is a reference
to the right arguments.
If you have a function
that just references omega,
it's a prefix function.
The next one, plus double,
is an infix function,
because it references both
alpha, the left argument,
and omega.
And then the fibonacci function
there is a multi-line function.
The omega equals 0 is a guard.
So it says, if this is true,
then the result is simply that.
Otherwise it continues.
And the dell is a recursion,
so it's calling itself again.
Let's see, how are
we doing for time?
Yeah.
So there's a whole bunch
of functional forms.
We're going to be
using some of these,
so I won't really
go into them now.
But let's go back and look at
one of the new functional forms
that I think is kind of
fun, that wasn't there
when Backus was looking at it.
So here is a function,
1 plus the reciprocal
of the right argument.
That returns 2.
If you apply it twice,
and three times,
it's heading towards
the golden ratio,
for those of you who
recognize the math.
Now, it gets a bit
tedious if you have
to do that again and again.
So there's a power
operator-- which
you see is a very similar
symbol to the mathematical
exponentiation, it just
has a dieresis above it--
where you can say, execute,
repeat the function
in this case, 4 times, 5 times.
Or create a little
lambda function,
which takes the right argument,
and applies it that many times.
And apply that each to iota 10.
And you can see we're
getting closer and closer
to the golden ratio.
But then there's
an extension to it,
where if the right operand is
not a number but a function,
then that function is applied
between successive results,
and the iteration terminates
when it returns true.
So this will continue until
we get to the fixed point,
and we have the golden ratio.
I think we're running
a little bit-- I'm
talking too much, as always.
So, I'm going to skip
over a little bit here.
We saw an example
of a user-defined--
we will see a slide with
some user-defined operators.
So you can write
user-defined operators
using the same curly
bracket notation.
But you refer to the operands
as alpha alpha and omega omega.
Works pretty much the same way.
So, in addition to these
new functional forms,
and if I don't talk
too much, we'll
see pretty much all of them
in some live code a little bit
later.
Here's a slide with
a postfix operator,
because it refers
only to alpha alpha;
and a dyadic, or infix,
operator referring both
to alpha alpha and omega omega.
But I don't really have time
to spend as much time on that
as I hoped.
Anyway, so there's a gap here.
You notice there's a
big hole in the middle.
Because there's one
thing that Iverson
couldn't figure out how to get
a good notation for in APL.
And that's a
mathematical notation
where you are adding
two functions together,
which in math, you would write
f plus g in parentheses of x.
And the story goes that
he's been searching for this
for a couple of decades.
Arthur may know more of
that story than I do.
And then on the plane on the
way back from an APL conference
in Australia, he woke up.
The sun came through
the window, and he
realized that the solution
was just to write f plus g x.
Because that was a
syntax error in APL.
You can't have a train of three
functions with no argument
if you put them in parentheses.
So that was exactly the
syntax he was looking for.
But of course being
Iverson, he wasn't
satisfied to have a
syntax for f plus g.
He's thinking that it could
be any three functions.
So there's a general definition
of a train of three functions.
f g h, that gives
you a function which,
if it has a right argument, it's
f of x and h of x, so the two
functions on either side.
And then the result is piped
into the middle function, which
is why that's
referred to as a fork.
Because it's bringing
the functions together
to the central function.
And if it's dyadic, it
extends the same way.
And then you can also
have a definition
for a train of two
functions together,
which is called an atop,
but it's really just a fork
that only has one arm.
So are those useful?
Or is it just--
So, we've seen the definition.
But it turns out that
something quite as ordinary
as the average is a fork,
because the average is
the sum divided by the count.
So, plus, reduce, divide, and
the function called tally.
You can see it's a
four-fingered animal,
I guess, counting 1, 2, 3,
4, the symbol for tally,
and there you are.
And you can also take
derived functions,
so the max reduce,
and the min reduce,
and the comma in
between is also a fork.
And in fact they extend.
The notation is such that
they nest from the right.
So that's the plus reduce
forked with the fork defined
by max reduce and min reduce.
So you can get this syntax
where you can say, well, give me
the sum, give me the maximum,
and give me the minimum.
It's not actually an
array of functions.
But when you use it this way, it
works as that kind of notation.
Now, the original
title of this talk
was Pragmatic
Functional Programming.
How many people
here would say they
are functional programmers?
It's not that many.
So I have a little
section here where
I show the APL equivalents of
Scheme examples, and so on.
Maybe I'll skip the live
code, since there was only,
I think, three people
who put their hands up.
But as you can see--
and I think we've
seen most of these in
the live code already--
most of the classical
functional forms
from a language like Scheme have
very simple equivalents in APL.
Juxtaposition creates
lists, and so on.
And you're not
Scheme programmers,
so I'll skip over
that one as well.
One of the things,
though, that I
think I do want to
spend some time on,
is sort of talking
about how when
you write idiomatic code in APL,
it generalizes to higher ranks.
It's rank invariant code.
So in Scheme, the definition
of a vector product
and the matrix multiplication
are quite different.
There's a lot more code
there in the matrix form.
So here is a function, the
question mark 6, do it again.
Any guesses for what this does?
Generates random numbers.
The right argument gives
the range of integers.
Now if you parse it in
array, it then applies that.
So now we've rolled four dice.
This reshape
function can be used
to generate an array
of any rank and shape.
So the 10 reshape of
6 gives you ten 6's.
So I can say I want to roll
10 dice using this expression.
Now I'm setting the
random seed here so
that I get some numbers
that are going to work
for the next few lines of code.
So I roll 10 dice, and now
I want to do some analysis.
So we haven't really seen
any logical functions yet,
but they also work
in the same way.
They are all scalar functions.
So throws equals 5
returns-- well you
might expect some
kind of Boolean array.
And, in fact, APL programmers
call this a Boolean array,
but actually it's
a 1 bit integer.
We have 1 bit
integers, 8 bit, 16,
32 bit integers in
the implementation.
And the nice thing about
them being integers
is that they are in
the domain of all
the mathematical functions.
So if I want to know how
many throws were equal to 5,
I can just write
this expression.
And I can use this Outer
Product thing to do
a whole bunch of comparisons.
So Outer Product takes
all the items on the left,
and all the items on
the right, and combines
them using the function.
The null dot equal-- null
dot is the Outer Product,
and the equals is the
function that you're applying.
So I can find out how many there
were of each one of the six
alternatives by
writing plus reduce,
iota 6, null dot
equals, and my throws.
And so now I'm
generating a million--
I'm rolling a million dice
with the same expression.
And you can see that
doesn't take-- well,
on a modern computer, you might
not expect that to take time.
But in an interpreted
language, you
might think it would
take significant time.
But of course, there's
virtually no interpretation
going on here.
You could almost think of the
APL expression as Bytecode.
It's diving straight into
highly optimized C code, that's
using the 1 byte integer data
type, because the range is six.
And it can do this
extremely fast.
And if you build user-defined
functions based on the APL
primitives, of course without
really having to do anything.
So I say, the square root
is omega to the power 0.5.
I have a function which
is also rank invariant,
because it's just parsing those
arrays to primitive functions.
I can call it on our 2 by 4
mat that we defined earlier.
And I can define the
hypotenuse as the square root
of the Inner Product with power.
So I take the left argument, the
right argument, I square them,
and I do a plus reduction
of the result of that.
And I take the square root.
So the hypotenuse is 5.
Print precision 6.
But again, this function
just applies without me
having to write any loops.
It would apply to
arguments of higher ranks.
And in fact, if you have a
dyadic user-defined function,
it can be used with
most of these operators
in the same way as a primitive.
So this is the plus
dot hypotenuse.
So it's the plus reduction
of the hypotenuse map
on these vectors.
So you can combine.
And some people, if you're
coming from a typical software
engineering background,
you'll say, well,
this business that APL can only
have left argument and right
argument.
You're going to need more
arguments, three arguments,
four arguments.
But as soon as you allow
that, then the beauty
of these operations, the
mathematical operations,
collapses.
And you end up in
a language which
has lots of parentheses and
stuff, and can do more stuff,
but isn't a tool of thought for
non-software engineer users,
which is where most of the
really successfully APL users
are coming from.
Sort of any kind of engineer
other than a software engineer.
And the Inner Product is
also carefully designed
to extend to higher ranks.
So here we have a
vector plus dot times.
But if we have our
matrix, then we
can say matrix plus
dot times in a vector.
And that will do
the plus dot times,
taking each vector on
the left and reusing
the single vector, which
is available on the right.
Mat or dot equals 7, the
7 is extended to a vector,
and then reused.
And we can find out if any
of the rows of the matrix
contain a 7.
We can make ourselves--
the first symbol
there is transpose.
So make a 3 by 4
matrix with those rows,
and then turn them into columns.
So we have a matrix
variable with 2 rows,
and a coefficients
matrix with 3 columns.
And then matrix multiplication
is still the same symbol,
plus dot times,
because it's just
cycling through the
rows on the left,
and the columns on the right.
Oh, three dimensions.
AUDIENCE: Is that a unary minus?
MORTEN KROMBERG: A unary minus.
Good question.
So it's the high minus.
I should have mentioned that.
Yes.
In APL, the normal low
minus is a function.
It's a prefix function that
applies to the whole array.
So APL has to use a
different symbol for entering
negative constants.
So we use a high minus for that.
Sorry, I should
have mentioned that.
It's just second-nature,
and forgotten 30 years ago.
Good question.
Yep?
RUSSELL HARMON: Just a reminder,
if people ask questions, either
repeat it, or give them a mic.
MORTEN KROMBERG: Yep.
OK.
So, I'll try to
remember that next time.
So here's a cube.
2 by 3 by 4.
Reshape of iota 24.
Now, we can do the plus
reduction of cubed.
That works on the
vectors as it did before.
So, we have a 2 by 3 by 4
matrix, we do a plus reduction,
we lose the last dimension,
we get a 2 by 3 array
back, which is the sum
of each one of the rows.
We have a slash with
a bar through it,
which says do the
plus reduction,
but doing it on the
leading dimension.
So it's going to be doing
the plus reduction down
through the planes, so we get
the sum of the two planes.
And of course, if
it's n dimensional,
we can't keep adding
symbols for all the cases.
We have a special symbol for
the first and last dimension.
But you can also,
in brackets-- this
is a slight anomalous
syntax-- but we
can direct the reduction to go
along a particular dimension.
In this case, go
down the columns.
Now, the tally is the length
of the leading dimension.
So that's 2 in this case.
If we define our
average function
as the sum along the
leading dimension divided
by the tally, which is
the length of the leading
dimension, it still
works with a vector,
because that just
has one dimension.
So that's fine.
Sorry, the resolution
has changed a bit here.
But the average
on the cube is now
going along the first dimension.
So it's summing the
planes, and dividing
by the number of planes.
But there's a nice interaction
with one of the newer operators
that's been added
since Backus' time.
There's a rank operator.
So we can say, apply
the function average
rank 1, which means, split the
argument array into sub-arrays
of rank 1.
So in this case, we would get
a 2 by 3 frame of vectors,
and compute the averages.
So the average function
is applied to each row.
And that gives you, not
surprisingly, the average
of each one of those rows.
What's interesting, if you
take this function, which
is written to compute the
average along the leading
dimension, and you
apply it rank 2,
that means you're
parsing to that
function a matrix each time.
So you take the
rank 2 sub-arrays,
of which there are 2.
Each one is 3 by 4.
And you parse the
average function to that,
and you can compute the
average of the columns.
And then if you parse it
rank 3 that's, in this case
since it's three dimensional,
that's the same as parsing
the original array, and
it does the computation
on the first dimension.
So using this rank
conjunction, or operator,
we can compute the
average along any one
of the dimensions of the array,
using that same piece of code.
Question?
AUDIENCE: How do you go
about unshaping the cube
and averaging over all the
numbers instead of [INAUDIBLE]?
MORTEN KROMBERG: If
you wanted to average
all the numbers,
the comma-- Sorry,
the question is,
how do I average
all of the numbers in
the cube without regard
to the structure of the cube?
What I would do then is use
a function called ravel.
The comma, prefixed comma,
simply removes all structure
from an array.
So the average of
cube would be that.
Or, of course, you
could apply average
repeatedly losing-- well, yeah,
in this case that would work.
But that's not a safe
technique always.
OK.
Now, one of the things, the
fact that the functions all
map implicitly,
allows you to do is
write what I would call
sort of switch-free logic.
So if I have some data
here, 4 element array,
and I wanted to pick
an item of the array
if it was greater than 5.
But if it was less than 5, I
wanted the value 5 instead.
Then in a traditional
programming language,
I would have written something,
if data sub I, make a loop,
and then if the element
is greater than 5 keep it,
otherwise return something else.
But in APL, you would
just say data max 5.
And element by
element, it would take
the greatest five, and
the corresponding item
of the array.
Now, if we wanted
to, for example,
increment each item
of data, depending
on whether it lived
up to some condition.
So we said, if the item is
an element of this list,
then increment it by 1,
otherwise leave it as it is.
Then in APL, you can say data
plus, data element 3, 7, 15,
because data element
3, 7, 15, returns
an array of the same
shape as the left argument
for each item, telling
you whether it's
a member of the set provided
as the right argument.
And that Boolean array can just
be added to the original data.
So if I wanted to add
2 in for each case,
then I would say data
plus 2 times data
is an element of something.
I don't know how many
people here write CUDA code,
or GPU code?
Because I've been told
that the kind of code
you need to write there, where
you have a bunch of processes
executing in lockstep, is
very similar to writing code
like this.
And you can also merge.
So I've got two arrays
here, x and y. x is 1,
2, 3, 4; y is 10, 20, 30, 40.
And I want to pick x
if the flag is true,
or I want to pick the
corresponding element of y
if it's false.
Then I would say x times
flags plus y times not flags.
And I can implement again.
I can do a lot of
parallel processing
without writing loops.
So, you might say, well, if this
stuff is so wonderful, where
have we all been?
How many people here
had heard of APL?
Oh, you had.
OK.
So, I should have asked at the
beginning what you had heard.
But one of the
reasons you generally,
at least as a software engineer,
hear very little about APL
is that the people, the
successful APL users,
I would claim, are people who
are any-- as I said before,
any kind of engineer other
than a software engineer.
So they don't really
feel comfortable
discussing programming.
They're solving some kind
of actuarial problem,
or chemical engineering problem.
They don't go to
software conferences.
They absolutely
hate it when they
have to change the way
that they do things.
So when the PC came
along, and they
were using APL on the
mainframe, they said,
what is the advantage of this?
I have to take my own backups.
If it breaks, it's
my own problem.
And a lot of the usage of APL
simply died with the mainframe,
because the people didn't
realize the technology were
changing under foot.
And then we came into
this really dark period.
I think even for people who
were software engineers,
this was a very difficult time,
where the APIs were changing.
And where APL programmers had
been able to write actually
pretty nice user interfaces,
and so on, on the mainframe,
they suddenly had to try and
adapt to all these software
engineering paradigms that
meant nothing to them.
And they really struggled
a lot in that period.
Fortunately, I would say, this
seems to have been temporary.
The new APIs that
are coming out now,
the more object-oriented
frameworks like the .NET
framework, the Java frameworks,
self-describing systems that
can be used in very much the
same way as APL programmers are
used to.
They've got reflection.
They can type expressions,
and experiment, and so on.
It looks like we can start
providing APL users again
with tools for building
user interfaces,
web-based interfaces,
for example,
that they will be able to use.
And of course, the
focus in the rest
of the community on
functional programming,
and the need to take use
of parallel hardware, which
is appearing everywhere,
is giving us,
I think, some
courage to reappear.
Functional programming
took about 80 years
to catch on from the first
ideas were mentioned.
Object-oriented programming
probably about 20
from simular until Xerox started
using it really with Smalltalk
and so on.
Arrays are now
about 50 years old.
If you want to successfully
build a group to use APL,
I would say you need the
right mix of domain experts
and software engineers.
You can't just do with
the domain experts,
because they'll build
things that will break.
But you need to allow
them the freedom
to experiment with
writing applications.
Be pragmatic.
We encourage a functional
style of programming,
but we don't demand it.
And what we're starting
to think, I think,
is that languages like
APL-- maybe not APL
itself, maybe
something that Google
will invent that will
embed some of these ideas--
will be the solution
to the next big problem
after concurrency, which
is simply complexity.
You need much more
powerful tools
where the domain experts
can bring their knowledge
to bear directly on the data.
Because if they
have to explain it,
even using agile
techniques to somebody,
it's already too late.
There are some customers,
or some organizations,
who are happy to talk about
the fact that they use APL.
Typically, they
are either sort of
slightly embarrassed by
using this really left-field
technology.
Or they consider it
to be a secret weapon
that they don't
want to talk about,
because it increases
their productivity so much
they'd rather not talk
about it for that reason.
But there are quite
a few people using
it to build some very
significant applications.
So, I mean, it's been 50
years, 52 years, I think.
A lot of the early criticism of
APL, I think, was quite valid.
And we've been working hard
on addressing a lot of it.
Today, our elevator
pitch is this text
that's up on the screen now.
We would say, we are an
array-first, multi-paradigm
programming language.
So we also support
functional styles.
We have object orientation.
You can create
classes that can be
used in external object-oriented
frameworks, et cetera.
But it's still very much based
on an APL language kernel.
I do need to spend one
minute on this one.
So you might think, if
you were using Scheme,
or some other similar language,
that these two expressions
are logically equivalent.
Right?
In fact, the first one's
better, because it consists
of English language statements
that people can easily
relate to, whereas
the one at the bottom
is a pretty weird-looking
mathematical statement.
But once you get
used to using APL,
and you look at that second
statement there, you think,
hang on.
But that's just the plus
reduce iota each of iota 6.
So, I can blend
those two together.
And of course, the plus
reduce of the first n
integers is really just
the argument plus times 1
plus the argument
divided by 2, applied
to each one of those functions.
And when you've looked at
that for a little while,
you realize that that's actually
just the plus scan of iota,
of the first 6.
But sometimes you need to be
experimenting interactively
with these things.
Before it's easy to see these.
But our experience is,
at least the people
who do get used to
this, it's really
worthwhile learning
the symbols, and being
able to apply what you
learned in school doing
math, physics, whatever,
directly in your programming.
Well, since Arthur
is here, I really
want to show you this
one also, because this
is one of my favorite quotes.
By Arthur Whitney here, the
inventor of the K language.
I think this is very, very true.
A very, very true statement.
And I think I'll leave it
there, and take some questions.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: What is 0.1 plus 0.2?
MORTEN KROMBERG: 0.1 plus 0.2.
The question is,
what is 0.1 plus 0.2.
It's 0.3.
AUDIENCE: Are those doubles?
MORTEN KROMBERG: Well, APL
really only recognizes numbers.
And it's doing everything it can
to hide the fact that it might
be using a variety of different
internal representations
from you.
So if you compute something,
and it collapses to all zeros,
then you end up with one
of these Boolean arrays,
a bit per element.
And in fact, the
interpreter spends
quite a lot of time trying
to collapse data types.
As it runs, it will
occasionally see
whether it can collapse
down to a smaller data type.
But the illusion that
we're trying to preserve
is that as a mathematical
notation, we just have numbers.
We don't really
recognize numeric types.
AUDIENCE: So, this is a
really, really nice notation
for linear algebra,
and stuff that's
sort of isomorphic
to linear algebra.
Could we expand this onto
more abstract algebra?
Like could I do this computation
over like a monoid, or a ring?
Because that would be
really nice for my software
engineering.
Or has anybody thought
about this stuff?
MORTEN KROMBERG:
Sorry, a monoid?
AUDIENCE: Operator of a
set with a closed operator
that's associated
and has an identity.
So like lists, and strings,
and max, and integers.
MORTEN KROMBERG:
No, I mean, I think
people did look
at that early on,
people who also were using
other programming languages.
Today, their usage
is really focused
on numerical applications,
and data mining applications,
and so on, where you're doing
a lot of number crunching.
So, I don't have a good
answer to that question.
AUDIENCE: You said
you're mainly focused
on numeric applications,
but I'd still
like to know, how do you
deal with promotion, or when
an overflow occurs?
And in this case, you're
probably not using
a double, or i3 floating point.
So, the question is, when do you
use big [? data ?] small end,
fixed precision stuff, and
floating precision stuff.
How do you choose that?
MORTEN KROMBERG: If you want
to go to decimal, higher,
we also support quadruple
precision decimal,
the IEEE format.
But that is a conscious
choice by the user.
They have to say, I want to have
much higher precision decimals.
Because those have a very
significant cost associated
with them.
But normally we go through
1 bit, 8 bit integers, 16,
32-bit integers.
We'll blow up into
doubles, and we also
consider complex numbers
to be in that continuum
of numeric representations.
And that's all done
completely automatically.
You can influence it, but
generally that's frowned upon.
You might do that
if you need to cast
a type to parse it
to some C program,
or something like that.
But generally in an APL
program, you wouldn't do that.
RUSSELL HARMON: I've
got a few questions
from our remote offices.
So, has APL been used on
large data sets that require
techniques such as sharding?
MORTEN KROMBERG:
Yes, it certainly
has by some of those customers.
But it's not something
that we provide support
for at the moment
natively in the language,
other than that you can map
an array to a mapped file.
But at the language level,
we don't provide tools
to deal directly with sharding.
AUDIENCE: Do you have any
crazy one-liners to show?
MORTEN KROMBERG:
Well, I mean, there
was the one that Russ sent
out in the invitation.
I don't know how crazy it is.
Let's see, can we find it.
Write this expression
for finding
all the primes between 1 and r.
Which is one of
those things that-- I
don't know where
this image came from,
but it's sort of an
example of really bad APL
code from the early
days, because it
modifies the right argument.
The first thing you do in
this expression is you take r,
and you reassign it to
the one drop of something.
And today, you would
want to write it
as one of these lexically
scoped things, where
that temporary array you
needed was a local variable.
But do you want an
explanation of how that works?
I mean, it's quite simple, so.
No?
Basically it's doing
an Outer Product.
All the numbers
between 1 and r, it's
multiplying them, doing
the Outer Product,
doing all the multiplications.
And then seeing
where the number is
an element of all of those
products, of everything.
So it, I mean it's a very direct
expression of what it means
for something to be prime.
But of course, it's
hideously inefficient.
Although it's so
short that you could,
at the interpreter level,
you could recognize
that as an idiom and
say, well, the guy's
obviously trying to
compute the prime numbers.
And that's one of the
advantages of this notation.
If you think about
that example in Scheme
with the plus
reduction, and so on,
I think the classical
thinking today
is, you write that
kind of expression,
and then some very clever
optimizing compiler
is going to detect the
loops within loops.
And it's going to fuse
them, and get rid of them.
Whereas in APL, you have these
much higher-level constructions
that an even an
interpreter can optimize.
You don't actually
need-- I mean,
we also want to do
loop fusion and stuff,
and we're working on
writing a compiler.
But it's much easier to
write highly optimized idiom
recognition in APL than I
think it is in most languages.
RUSSELL HARMON: Another
question from a road office.
I thought something like
APL in its environment
is what spreadsheets
should have been like.
Comments?
MORTEN KROMBERG:
What spreadsheets
should have been like.
Yeah, I mean, I think a lot
of the earliest spreadsheets
on mainframes were
actually implemented
in APL by APL users.
But spreadsheets provide
much more than APL does.
APL is a programming language,
whereas the spreadsheets
have all the formatting
and very simple
ways of storing data
built into this package.
It's sort of a
mash-up kind of thing.
I think that quite
a few applications
where people would prototype
them in a spreadsheet,
and then rewrite them
in APL, because they
needed more structure.
Spreadsheets are incredibly
dangerous things,
because you can
over-type an expression,
and you realize 10 years later
that you haven't actually
been recomputing that value.
Whereas APL gives you a
lot of the same features
as a spreadsheet,
but it does require
you to be a bit
more disciplined,
and do a bit more work.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: I have two questions.
I'll let you decide which
of them you want to answer,
or both.
I was wondering if you could
say something, especially
perhaps since Arthur is
here, about the relationship
between APL and J and
K, and when one would
look into one or the other.
Why would I learn
APL versus J or K?
Different question
which is similar
is, for people who are less
familiar with these array-based
languages, why would I
look at this these days
versus something like R,
or MATLAB, or Mathematica?
MORTEN KROMBERG: Maybe
do the last one first.
Why APL rather than R, or
Mathematica, or MATLAB?
I mean, those tools have all
been extremely successful,
but I think not due to the
beauty of the programming
language.
It's more that
they have collected
extremely good
libraries, and they've
managed to present them in a
way where people-- engineers who
needed to solve a problem
very, very quickly
found the things they needed.
For whatever application
they were doing,
you could solve 95% of what you
needed with standard libraries.
But when you need to go beyond
what the standard libraries can
do, that's where I think
APL, the users that we
have are typically people who
are operating outside the 90%.
They have new ideas about
calculations that aren't
available in those packages.
I think APL could be a really
good future implementation
language for many
of those packages.
I sort of understand
why they didn't
use APL when they started
those products back
in the '90s, when the
APL interpreters really
weren't up to it.
Today, I think it
might be different
if they were starting again.
A lot of those people
did come out of APL.
On the question of when would
you use K versus J versus APL,
I mean, that's very
difficult. Clearly, K,
if you're doing
anything that has
to do with really large volumes
of data, and real-time trading,
they would run rings
around an APL interpreter.
I think APL products,
certainly like ours,
have much more capability in
terms of interfaces to .NET.
We allow you to create classes
that can be consumed directly
by C#.
We have interfaces
to databases, and are
much more of a general
purpose programming language.
I think better
debugging tools, I
would say, at least
at the moment.
Same is probably
true for J. With J,
I would say, we're actually
at the moment in the process
of adopting a lot of the
language features that were put
into J. J is sort of like an
increased instruction set APL
system, whereas I think--
Arthur, correct me
if I'm wrong-- I would say K
is really a risk APL system.
Right?
We only need this, and throw
out the stuff that is sort
of "bloat," and
make it run really,
really fast on humongous data.
Is that fair?
ARTHUR WHITNEY: Yep.
MORTEN KROMBERG: Yeah.
We're sort of the
general purpose tool.
J is very focused on teaching.
So they have fantastic
mathematical labs,
and examples of how to do math.
Yes, Russ?
RUSSELL HARMON: What
community-contributed libraries
are there?
MORTEN KROMBERG:
That's really one
of the weak points of the
language as it stands today,
and one of the things that we
see as our biggest challenge
for the next few years.
We've been building-- and
I'm talking about Dyalog
specifically, we've
been building frameworks
to deal with source
code in Unicode files
rather than the binary
formats that APL has typically
used in the past.
And we are really trying to
construct an environment where
we will see much more user
participation in terms
of building libraries than
we've seen in the past.
Typically, APL
vendors have provided
nearly all the libraries in the
past, and that's a weakness.
And it has a lot to do with
what I mentioned before,
that the APL users
aren't really motivated.
They're not software engineers.
They're trying to
price a new insurance
product to sell next week.
And when they've
done that, their boss
is going to give them
another problem to solve.
And they're not really-- Python
and these languages which
have some similarity
to APL have, I think,
a larger traditional
software engineering
part of the
community, which means
they've been better at
building that kind of thing.
AUDIENCE: All the
symbols are in Unicode?
MORTEN KROMBERG: All the
symbols are in Unicode, yeah.
And have been.
I mean, they were
in Unicode 1.0.
Yep.
So, I mean, Unicode has
been so good for us.
We just use sub version, or
whatever the latest thing is.
We are moving to Git,
like everybody else.
And it's just Unicode.
I mean, all the diff tools out
there just work with APL now.
You don't have to do anything.
Everything just works.
Yes?
OK, I'm not sure.
Yeah, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So about
the user libraries,
user-generated libraries,
or user contribution
to the language.
You said you guys have been--
MORTEN KROMBERG: Oh, yeah.
We're working on tools to
make APL development much more
similar to traditional
development.
So using source code
management systems,
dependency management,
tools, build tools,
that everybody else is using.
Whereas in the past, APL
programmers have tended to--
or the large APL shops would
all build their own source code
management tools,
where the data was
stored in like spreadsheets,
binary, proprietary formats
from the various vendors.
But that's really changing.
And we can see the new
people coming into APL today,
compared to the
guys who started--
There was this big wave
of people who started
using APL in the '70s and '80s.
And then as the market faded
when the mainframe died,
those people carried on
being the main contributors.
And they really didn't have
a modern way of approaching
software development.
We can now see we have
a second wave of people
coming into the language, who
have a very different approach.
And it will probably change
things quite dramatically
over the next five
years, how APL is used.
AUDIENCE: So the other
language that I've used--
or the only language
which I've used
that's really significantly
Unicode-y in its operators is
Agda.
And it has this really,
really lovely Emacs mode,
where you can type right
arrow, and then it'll
insert a little
right arrow for you.
Is there something like
that, so I could write APL
in like a text editor, or a
terminal, or something that's
not an APL IDE?
MORTEN KROMBERG: There are at
least a couple of Emacs modes
out there if you
search for them.
Or send me an email, and I
will give you links to people.
We are in the process of-- we
just released this Mac version
last week.
And that's using a
completely new IDE.
We've had this Windows
product for a decade, where
nearly all the users have been.
We're sort of very much
a Win 32 application.
But we've now separated
the interpreter
from these data
streams, and we're
in the process of
publishing them.
And it'll be
possible for anybody
to write a front end to APL
in about another year, when we
finally finalize that format.
And then it'll become very
easy to write plug-ins
for Emacs, Eclipse,
whatever you want.
Yeah.
But we do already
have some people
who have built Emacs modes.
Yeah?
RUSSELL HARMON: I'm told
that Iverson originally
intended to have APL to natively
apply to arrays and trees.
What happened to the latter?
MORTEN KROMBERG: What
happened to the trees, Arthur?
ARTHUR WHITNEY: I don't know.
MORTEN KROMBERG: I
mean, the nested arrays
were added in 1983.
Before 1983, all the arrays were
just rectangular, flat arrays
the had to consist entirely
of numbers, or characters.
And then there was
this thing called
APL2, which came along from
IBM in 1984, where anything
could become-- any element of
an array could be another array.
And at that point, I
think, a lot of people
were thinking about
things to traverse trees.
Because clearly, if you
could have nested arrays,
you can have trees.
I think possibly a
part of the problem
is that the efficiency
is a problem.
Because you can write a very
highly optimized APL, or K,
or J interpreter.
When it's working
on flat arrays,
it can actually
outperform hand-coded C,
because it knows
things about how
you're combining operations.
Or it's better than
the hand-coded C
that you would normally
write, because you'd
have to go to superhuman
efforts to beat it.
Of course, hand-coded C can
always beat an APL interpreter.
But I think on trees,
because you would typically
be recursively going through
a structure where there's
a lot more pointers and so
on, you need a compiler to get
really efficient tree traverse.
Well, at least if the
trees have small nodes.
I don't know.
What do you say, Arthur?
ARTHUR WHITNEY: I
hadn't heard that.
MORTEN KROMBERG: Yeah, no,
that's definitely the case.
That, yes.
ARTHUR WHITNEY:
So, I don't know.
MORTEN KROMBERG: Ken had,
I think in the APL book,
there were ideas for notation
for tree traversal and so on.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
MORTEN KROMBERG:
It was called APL.
A Programming Language.
Which seems strange today
to software engineers,
of course, who say,
it doesn't look
like a programming language.
But of course, he
was doing math.
Right?
So for him, the
choice of words-- Ken
was always very careful with his
words-- it was exactly right.
It was for programming steps
of mathematical operations.
AUDIENCE: So, I've looked
at some tree stuff in J,
and I think some
of the challenges
are that a lot of tree
operations are incremental,
whereas array languages like to
operate on the entire data set
at a time.
Right?
And so when you break it
up into smaller operations,
then you kind of get
the interpreted overhead
coming in a little bit.
MORTEN KROMBERG: Yep,
I think that's what
I was trying to say.
Yeah, I agree.
That's a challenge.
Now, of course,
we are working-- I
don't know about the
other APL vendors--
but we are working quite
hard on compilers now.
I think Arthur is also
thinking about compilers.
There have been several
attempts through the ages
to write compilers for APL,
but on hardware 20 years ago,
they rarely succeeded
in speeding things up
by more than a factor of two.
And people couldn't be bothered.
They wouldn't accept the
inconvenience of a compiler
compared to this inalienable,
dynamic, interactive way
of life for a factor
of two improvement.
But today, the way
the hardware is
changing where you have
all this concurrency,
and the speed of the CPU
relative to the speed
of the memory has
changed dramatically
in the last decade.
The memory isn't getting any
faster, or not much faster,
but they can do all kinds
of crazy, clever stuff
inside the chips.
So the win from creating
a compiler today
could be orders of
magnitude speed up
rather than just
that factor of two
they were able to
achieve before.
So there's several people
working now on compilers,
I think.
And then, we can
get back into trees,
and extend the notation
to do tree traversal.
Here's something that one of
our customers has built in APL.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
MORTEN KROMBERG: I'm
getting some feedback.
So, this is a result of
an initiative in Finland,
where the government
decided to make
all of this 3D map data
available free-of-charge
to everybody.
And they launched a competition
for the best application
to take advantage of it.
And one of our users built this.
It's a game that he sells
to private individuals,
and to the search and rescue
operations in Finland.
We're out of time.
So we've had questions.
And maybe I'll just
leave that one up.
If you want to get
hold of it, TryAPL,
there are free versions
available for students.
If anybody here is really
interested, drop me a line,
and I'm sure we
can get you a copy.
So, that's it.
Thank you very
much for listening.
[APPLAUSE]